moi je pense que surtout du côté du
gouvernement ou du président de la
République on ne peut pas se contenter
de faire une accumulation de nom non il
y aura pas de dissolution non il y aura
pas de retrait du texte non il y aura
pas de changement du gouvernement la
seule chose qu'on voudrait c'est savoir
sur quoi il y a un oui parce que
l'accumulation de nom ça fait pas un oui
hein donc il y a bien un moment il
faudra trouver une sortie de crise il
faudra trouver une solution on aimerait
avoir des éléments de solution de la
part du gouvernement plusieurs de cette
stratégie du gouvernement qui semble
essayer d'enjamber la crise autour de
des retraites puisque les syndicats ils
l'ont vu ils l'ont vécu comme tel il
refuse de tourner la page et d'ouvrir
comme le souhaite le gouvernement
d'autres séquences de concertation c'est
ce qu'a dit Cyril Chabanier de la CFTC
ce matin non mais clairement le
gouvernement ou le président de la
République espère que pour Isma
maturation appelons ça comme on veut les
gens se lassent de l'affaire des
retraites et passe à autre chose avec
les vacances de Pâques avec le reste ça
ne passera pas comme ça il faut qu'il y
ait des gestes il faut qu'il y ait des
avancées il faut qu'il y ait non pas du
sur autre chose mais dur dialogue sur le
côté social pour avancer sinon on n'aura
pas de solution positive Patrick canin
appelle à mettre en pause cette réforme
vous pensez que c'est possible même
avant la sanction définitive du Conseil
Constitution il faut atteindre la
décision du Conseil parce que si le
Conseil dit encore il reste des jours ah
bah oui mais
ça je n'y peux pas grand chose la
décision de conseils soit elle sent
surtout auquel cas est plus de texte
soit censure à certains nombre
d'éléments auquel cas le texte devient
compliqué à gérer en toute état de cause
on est dans une situation de blocage et
cette situation de blocage se répercute
sur le Parlement qui aujourd'hui voit un
gouvernement n'osant plus présenter le
moindre texte un gouvernement vitrifié
vous me direz juste avant cette
interview
[Musique]